thank you for this movie I mean having a
number two is so that sounded wrong
that's not what I meant that is not this
is not the way to start an interview
number two it is very important now go
on yes yes the sequel is what you mean
I'm very excited
you know well the first picture came out
almost 30 years ago I think it was 30
years ago and uh we we went on with our
lives and we didn't pay any attention to
it and then a few years later we started
getting these gigantic checks well not
gigantic what kind of big checks I don't
know because we all we're all like you
know we would get royalties or residuals
whatever they're called and we we would
say Gina something going on here and so
we called and called around and said oh
it seems to be doing very well it's on
television now it's on TV so we saw it's
on television at Halloween then the year
after that it was on television two
weeks and then four weeks and then then
a month and a half or whatever and there
was the whole month of October for the
from the first to the month of October
and suddenly these three characters were
everywhere online you could get Winnie
and Mary and Sarah costumes you could
get uh people were dressing up like us
at Halloween which was very surreal
because my daughter out for trick or
treating and she'd be like Mom isn't
that you oh yeah yeah it was a bizarre
it was the whole trajectory of the
entire uh movie The this movie is
complete it's so bizarre I've never been
through anything like it yeah and I've
really it's really fan it's fan motor I
didn't see any change in my royalties oh
I'm sorry for you I need a battery start
on the call list but but I I did started
hearing about the fans and then of
course you know online there was groups
of them and just watching it it's really
a wonder you know you just watch it like
wow because we've all done a lot of
projects and once you do it you move on
it's out of your hands so to see how it
just progressed and got people got so
into it was really interesting it was I
I had never had I mean I was in a movie
called Sister Act that had a lot of you
know popularity but I didn't see people
dressed up like nuns all year long
I think it might have happened though I
think that did happen also
um you know in this movie A spell goes
wrong and you could
too much away families everything
um is that sort of the the underlying
theme of this movie
yeah I think family yes I think that's
an underlying theme of the movie also
Sisterhood and also uh having each
other's backs you know watching out for
each other forgiving each other there's
a lot of forgiveness in this picture
there's a lot of misunderstanding
there's a lot of misunderstanding and
coming to the coming and coming to the
truth yeah digging around until you find
the truth it's got it's full of
wonderful themes and it's the thing that
one of the things that I love about it
is that it's it's so wholesome I mean
yeah I'm very I'm I know everybody
thinks I have like the big worst mouth
in the world but truly I I love child I
love being a kid and when I was a kid we
didn't see any of the stuff that you see
now you just didn't see any of the stuff
that you didn't see the violence you
didn't see oh no did you see now and so
I had this this Enchanted childhood and
I just wish everybody had all the all
children have that yeah in a funny way I
think the fact that this movie is is
wholesome and in fact All Families All
Families All Families including children
and children of all ages now you know
the The Young and the young at heart
it's just it's just it's kind of hopeful
I have to say I watched this movie I I
got a screener of it and I watched it
with my little girl who's home sick
right now with a cold and she was so in
it and it was so much fun she's nine
okay
to see her reaction and how excited she
was and then we got to have that
together I was like oh this is they did
it they did it you know when you got me
and you got her and we were both in it
and so congratulations like it that's
just amazing to be able to do that also
that's a lovely thank you that's lovely
really wonderful yeah yeah it was really
great and what was it like for you to
all be back on set together I know
you're missing your partner here today
um but what was it like to be back
together on set because it's just magic
I think that there's something we have
some something the three of us have
something together that I've I've never
had with another I mean I've had Parts
girls standing behind me my whole life
but this is so very different you have a
good good chemistry we she has her
improvisational moments that she does
and Sarah has her Lane that she Strays
in and out of and she and she tries a
lot of things and they all succeed and
and I'm just like I'm just this bull in
a china shop so and I'm totally in my
lane doing yet together we make a hole
it's great but there but this is this is
this is our leader this character is our
world this is this is from which we come
well and it's all rage you know it's all
Ray yeah emotions and yet something
positive don't don't give it away but
what about the um the monologue that she
had at the end and the
boom right there there it is okay so I
have a suggestion why don't the three of
you do a rom-com together how much fun
would that be now that would be fun that
would be fun do we what what do we get
what do we no I think that would be so
much fun between the three of you we
need to see that
okay maybe we'll join the Peace Corps
yeah how about this first scenario okay
we're going looking for for gold in in
the in in Peru I mean I mean we could do
anything together we could climb Mount
Everest together and it would still be
funny
because I could never climb even two
stairs to Mount Everest
me too me too but I would love to see
something more
um with all of you I just think it would
be it would be spectacular
um thank you you know Halloween
um Sister Act absolutely I'd love to be
in Sister Act with you absolutely it
could be the second mother's appearance
oh I'd love that
oh my goodness and I will just I'll do
all the behind the scenes interviews if
you could just hire me all
the way I'll do that stuff I'm gonna put
it in my contract absolutely won't do it
unless you're here perfect I mean the
way I started this interview really
shows you that we could just take it
anywhere so yeah
you really are going to be you know you
were before but you're going to again
for another generation of of children be
sort of that Tradition at Halloween what
does that feel like like there's
Christmas movies and those movies do
that and you you know you had the
original movie and you were part of that
Halloween tradition but now you get to
do it again for a whole generation of
kids what's that like
it's surreal isn't it I could have never
imagined it kind of enchanting it has I
mean it's like a it's like what being in
a Dream well that's what surreal is
right it is it's like being in a dream
like like I must be dreaming this that
this has happened yeah it's magical it's
Kismet it's nothing that you plan or
organize it's just a surprise you do a
film you don't know how people are going
to react to it how far into their hearts
and souls and Fantasies they're going
it's going to come so that this occurred
I don't think any of us could ever have
you couldn't have predicted it no
predicted we couldn't have been but to
stand behind stand outside of yourself
and to stand outside the world of the of
the movie and to watch it happen you
just you know you know you're like a
chicken what's that over there what is
that over there I mean it but makes no
sense and yet it makes all the sense
to live through it is absolutely
thrilling I gotta say it's so much it's
thrilling
so I have to go before I say something
else inappropriate and it's wrong so I'm
gonna go all right you're wondering I
love you guys and thank you so much
thank you